[Music]
cost of health care is a huge concern
for a lot of families and a florida
woman ended up with a hospital bill of
more than half a million dollars after
giving birth
despite having health insurance bc
bennett's story is part of our
continuing bill of the month partnership
with kaiser health news and npr
what happened was she switched health
insurance plans while her newborn was in
the nicu and she says that led to major
confusion over the billing
dorian is a healthy one-year-old now but
when he was first born prematurely in
november 2020 and rushed to the nicu
first time mom bc bennett was terrified
about his health i didn't even know if
he was born alive if he was still born
so i'm crying i'm very upset baby dorian
was in the hospital for about two months
before he was healthy enough to go home
then bennett got the hospital bill for
more than a half million dollars
i was
very upset when i saw the half a million
dollar bill
because i felt like i'd done everything
in my power to avoid them sending me
that huge bill
she had picked the hospital that was in
network for her united health care
insurance but in january 2021 while her
son was still in the nicu her employer
changed health plans to umr
instead of billing united health care
for 2020 and umr for 2021 the hospital
billed both policies for both years when
neither would cover the bill because of
the administrative error bennett was
charged more than 550 thousand dollars i
called the hospital several times just
to let them know hey you guys are
lumping the bill together you need to
split it out despite her calls the same
bill was sent again with a payment plan
of nearly 46 thousand dollars a month
which is ridiculous i don't have forty
six thousand dollars
to pay a month i was scared that i was
going to go into collections i hope that
by doing the story that they would
really think about
just healthcare from a holistic
standpoint
health is not just when you're in the
hospital and also has to do with how you
treat someone
after they've been discharged from the
hospital
the advent orlando hospital revised the
bill after kaiser health news contacted
it back in october bennett's more than
half a million dollar bill was then
updated to 300 total
in a statement united healthcare said it
did not receive the 2020 portion of the
hospital bill until this fall and it has
since paid that bill the hospital said
quote we apologize for the frustration
this caused
for future patients like mrs bennett who
may experience a change in insurance
during their treatment this case allowed
us to identify opportunities within our
system to improve the billing and
communications process close quote okay
that's good an opportunity the editor in
chief of kaiser health news dr elizabeth
rosenthal joins us now uh doctor good
morning to you
this is shocking for a lot of people i
can't imagine opening a bill and seeing
500 000
on it uh what should people do when
they're in a situation like this
well the problem here is that when
there's a snafu or a disagreement
between providers you know the patients
are left holding the bag and
you know this was not resolved until
nearly a year later after we called and
the weird thing is the aca the
affordable care act said the patients
had to be offered financial assistance
and many hospitals have these payment
plans but they're often automated so you
know if you take a bill of 550 000
and divide it by 12 and get 46 000 a
month that's absurd that's absurd they
should be embarrassed by that
it it is it is a big number pretty
eye-catching i don't know 46 000 a month
so you say it's the responsibility of
patience to uh to track down these
double billings or miss billings and
then sort it out so is the advice just
to make a lot of phone calls write a lot
of emails
well bc did everything in her power as
she said and i think what people need to
understand is the end of the year the
change over the year is is a perilous
time for patients healthcare has kind of
a y2k problem
you know your deductible resets your
plan may change the provider network may
change so you have to have your your
antenna up for all of those things
possibly and and the problem is computer
systems are not very good at kind of
saying oh yeah we understand what
happened here
bc was so what i suggest is first of all
don't pay the 46 000 a month even if you
have it which most people don't um the
second thing is go to your hr department
because your company has much more
leverage with these insurers than you do
individually and and last of all try and
send that payment plan to the hospital
ceo and say
really you expect people to pay this
um
come to bill of the month or contact
anna warner those are my two options uh
for sure yeah you can't deal with a
computer the computer doesn't care you
got to deal with a person if you can dr
rosenthal thank you very much